we have expressed interest we have made
clear uh to the russian federation uh
that uh we are seeking a conversation
between secretary of lincoln and foreign
minister lavrov uh before the secretary
spoke yesterday we had made contact uh
with our uh with the appropriate russian
counterparts to put in a call request uh
the russians acknowledged that call
request yesterday uh we have continued
to go uh back and forth uh as you know
foreign minister lavrov
is in the midst of travel so i don't
have any update to provide in terms of
when they may be able to connect
but we continue to discuss that in the
appropriate channels among the issues
that the secretary outlined that he
would broach
with foreign minister lavrov first and
foremost in this case uh is
the continued wrongful detention of
brittany griner
and paul whelan as part of that the
secretary said yesterday that we had put
forth put forth a substantial proposal
and that he would seek to use that call
to attempt to
move towards a resolution